l'éducation vise à transmettre un savoir
développer nos capacités de réflexion
apprendre l'art de vivre et pour cela
nous passons entre 24 et 48 heures par
semaine assis en cours pendant 10 ou 20
ans nous et notre corps qui nous amène
d'un lieu à l'autre et dont nous
apprenons si peu notre corps
n'aurait-elle pas aussi quelque chose à
nous apprendre
j'ai toujours voulu être danseur dès le
cp quand on me posait la question qu'est
ce que tu veux faire quand tu seras plus
grand jeu vous être danseur dans ma
famille nombreuse quand je dansais dans
le salon devant les invités on disait
que je voulais faire mon intéressant
mais c'est cette photo que j'ai conservé
d'un atelier de grande section
maternelle qui dit tout ce que
représentait pour moi la danse
sur cette photo je me vois laisser libre
cours à mon imagination
à travers ce mouvement je me sens libre
mes parents m'inscrivent donc à l'école
de danse de mon village
sa directrice marie christine robert
nous dit si bruno veut en faire son
métier
c'est l'opéra de paris à 10 ans je passe
donc le concours d'entrée à l'école de
l'opéra national de paris et j'y fais
toutes les classes
c'est l'école académique l'excellence de
la danse un milieu d'élite
on nous dit qu'au sein de cette élite
on ne sera jamais vraiment à la hauteur
sinon peut-être en faisant partie de ces
rares élus à être danseur étoile enfants
je vais très vite intégré ces règles me
rajouter même sur la discipline de
l'artiste insolent entre la table basse
et les vases du salon de ses parents je
deviens un bon soldat à charles ix
tout cela nous donne une formation
solide exceptionnelle qui me permet
aujourd'hui de vivre de ma passion mais
quelque part je me perds dans cette
formation d'excellence
je vais passer chaque année avec plus ou
moins d'encombrer les examens où
j'aurais pu être envoyés finalement
j'intègre le ballet de l'opéra national
de paris
le graal de sézanne et j'attends
tellement de ce temple de la danse je me
retrouve parmi 150 danseurs et dans une
organisation où il me semble on fait
passer la hiérarchie avant l'art de
danser je ressens surtout qu'on ne fait
pas vraiment attention à l'artiste que
j'aimerais devenir
et puis brigitte l'oeuf rêve qui était
directrice de la danse à l'opéra de
paris il ya un vide pina bausch à venir
travailler
pina bausch remonte son sacre du
printemps et fait passer des auditions
aux 150 danseurs sans connaître vraiment
son travail
je vais me jeter à bras le corps dans
ses auditions et j'ai la chance d'être
choisis
je vais me retrouver à 18 en dansant
dans la terre torse nu dans une horde
d'hommes face à des femmes en robe
transparente qui laisse apercevoir leur
corps je suis retourné par le travail
que nous demande pina je ne dors pas de
la nuit
refaisant la chorégraphie je me retourne
dans mes draps transpirant avec en
boucle la puissance de la musique de
stravinsky
c'est une révolution
je sais enfin pourquoi je fais ce métier
exprimé intensément des sentiments
indicible et cela passe profondément par
mon corps la forme doit être impeccable
mais c'est simplement un moyen pour dire
ses émotions
la compagnie de pina bausch le
tanztheater de wuppertal mme apprend
aussi que sur scène on peut représenter
l'humanité dans toute sa diversité des
grands des gros des petits déjeunes des
minces des vieux montrer des gens si
différents
c'est déjà un acte subversif par rapport
aux règles classiques c'est avant tout
un acte d'une grande beauté cette beauté
et cette liberté que m'apprend pina
c'est ma meilleure amie karine classe
piquion chanteuse est habitué de la
scène contemporaine qui va m'aider à la
trouver par moi même à cette époque mon
village natal roissy me propose
d'organiser un spectacle avec les
danseurs de l'opéra de paris pour ne pas
refaire un xxi ème gala avec les
danseurs de l'opéra
karine à l'idée originale que nous
fassions nos propres créations en
faisant ce spectacle je me rends compte
que la création est la meilleure façon
de m'exprimer librement
je trouve une respiration hors des murs
de l'opéra je travaille avec des
personnes choisies
j'aime le côté saltimbanque partage et
travail et je décide donc de pérenniser
cette aventure et nous créons notre
propre compagnie ainsi danse
chorégraphique
alors pourquoi je suis là ce soir pour
parler éducation c'est qu'avec ainsi
danse chorégraphique
je monte des activités pédagogiques qui
accompagne le spectacle dans un premier
temps des ateliers avec des enfants déjà
sensibilisés à la danse pour transmettre
ma passion je vais essayer de mettre en
application ce que j'ai appris j'ai
souffert dans mon éducation quand je me
suis senti un simple objet
au service d'une exécution parfaite et
j'ai pu me dépasser physiquement quand
on donner du sens aux mouvements que
j'avais à reproduire mon parcours m'a
donné un savoir très sophistiquée sur le
corps j'ai appris à l'écouté et à le
pousser dans de grandes exigences et
performance mais quand on est avec des
jeunes amateurs comment l'ambition peut
être la même je suis face à des enfants
qui aiment la danse mais qui ne
connaissent pas bien leur corps et si au
centre de cette réflexion je prenais
d'abord le corps autrement dit si je
prenais le corps comme un éducateur
qu'aurait-il à nous apprendre je vais
commencer mes cours par un simple
exercice de yoga et de respiration
je vais donner des instructions imagé
pour conduire l'exercice comme que le
coeur se trouve dans la cage thoracique
et que de respirer amplement lui fait de
la place certains enfants pour attirer
leur attention sont plus sensibles à des
points techniques comme inspiré par le
nez et d'expirer par la bouche mais
j'essaye toujours de donner des images à
travers mes corrections comme de
d'imaginer que son pied et un compas
pour faire des ronds de jambe au sol ou
de déployer ses bras comme dlc par
l'imagination que les enfants se
représentent leurs corps dans
l'éducation souvent on parle d'abord de
la forme ici j'essaye de mettre en avant
le côté ludique et le plaisir de
découvrir son corps par imagination
de cette manière les enfants prennent
conscience de leur propre corps mais
sans jugement de valeur
j'observe que les intrigues rapidement
les corrections et choses plus
compliquées
il commence à maîtriser les mouvements
on peut dire que le savoir commence à
prendre corps exit le fai va me proposer
un projet éducatif plus ambitieux dans
le programme dix mois d'école et d'opéra
c'est un programme destiné aux élèves
relevant de l'éducation prioritaire
un partenariat entre l'opéra national de
paris et le ministère de l'éducation
nationale permet aux classes de
s'immerger dans le monde de l'opéra
certaines classes peuvent s'inscrire
dans un projet artistique
on me demande donc de monter une
chorégraphie pour une classe de 6e 24
élèves
treize garçons aux filles les ateliers
amateurs avec incidence chorégraphique
me donne un certain appui mais l'enjeu
ici est clairement plus complexe
je suis face à des enfants d'horizons
très différents
loin du milieu de la danse et je dois
faire un spectacle je pars avec une
conviction m au centre du projet les
enfants avant même de penser à
construire une oeuvre ne pas fixer de
date butoir pour commencer à écrire la
pièce car il va nous falloir les
apprivoiser et les premiers rendez-vous
nous le confirment les enfants expriment
quasi unanimement je n'aime pas la danse
j'aime pas l'opéra c'est pour les vieux
c'est ennuyeux
j'ai pas envie de faire du spectacle
alors comment leur faire comprendre
combien la danse peut leur apprendre
quelque chose à nous de monter une phase
d'expérimentation et de leur faire
découvrir que le projet leur appartient
je vais partir des mêmes ateliers
qu'avec les amateurs c'est la partie la
moins évidente
il la trouve contraignante découvrir son
corps à partir d' équilibre et
d'étirements passe parfois par une
certaine douleur mais en jouant avec les
postures de yoga et leurs noms comme
celle de la montagne où l'arbre
cela invite leur imagination et oriente
sans qu'il s'en aperçoive leur
concentration sur le corps
nous créons également des ateliers plus
créatifs nous leur demandons ce qu'ils
aiment dans la vie et nous allons partir
de là les mettre au centre du jeu tu
aimes le foot ou l'escaladent et bien
regarde comme ça peut-être
chorégraphique maintenant vos mouvements
de foot tu vas le coupé par exemple
arrête ton pied imagine qu'il va sauter
autour
tu vois tu viens déjà de faire ton
propre mouvement ainsi nous leur
demandons de créer leur abécédaire six
mouvements qu'ils créent eux mêmes en
les nommant par leurs primes
maëlys 1 sera un jeté avec les deux bras
tendus christophe 3 un tour en l'air
comme avec les amateurs les enfants un
cumul de plus en plus de savoir cela
s'inscrit clairement dans leur corps il
progresse et cela se voit le projet a
aussi un impact plus large en la sq
warri dans la scolarité des enfants les
ateliers améliore le vivre ensemble et
la cohésion du groupe nous dit les
professeurs les résultats dans les
autres matières sont plutôt bons cela
confirme les études du mémoire café mon
assistante l'orage et d'un professeur
des écoles en quoi la danse de création
fait progresser les élèves dans toutes
les autres matières en écoutant les
enfants on se rend compte aussi que ce
projet les fait bouger dans leur
existence est la question que je me pose
finalement est-ce que d'avoir une
meilleure conscience de son corps comme
moyen d'expression fait bouger notre
rapport au monde
je laisse lors élise y répondre
interviewé à la radio elle affirme avec
laura et bruno on apprend des choses
concrètes plus concrète que dans les
autres matières les matous de français
cette réponse aujourd'hui me surprend
encore
elle retourne l'idée même que la danse
permettrait avant tout de fuir un
quotidien ce n'est pas un divertissement
c'est du concret c'est difficile d'être
l'acteur d'un projet et de l'analyser
j'observe juste que les enfants ont
modifié leur rapport au corps le corps
la chose la plus concrète qui nous
rattache à l'existence sans corps pas de
vie l'accumulation des savoirs cognitifs
et l'orientation principale de
l'éducation d'aujourd'hui on développe
également le virtuel
le numérique les avancées de la pensée
immatériel paraissent sans limite
la danse donne une connaissance physique
dont le corps et le cadre le corps n'est
pas exclusivement comme dans le sport un
moyen de performance mais aussi un moyen
d'expression dans leur pratique les
enfants éprouvent leur enveloppe
l'espace autour eau et en ne le touchez
le contact avec d'autres éléments
le contact avec autrui le corps leur
apprend quelque chose de notre condition
le spectacle est l'aboutissement de ce
projet les enfants de dix mois d'école
et d'opéra face au public doivent gérer
une pression énorme
être dans la lumière s'éteint des
exercices les plus difficiles à la fin
du spectacle chacun des élèves à une
partie solo où il dit on m'a appris à
danser comme ça mais moi je préfère
danser comme ça et chacun va s'exprimer
à sa manière rap hip hop acrobaties ou
tout autre chose
lorsque lucas prend la parole devant 600
personnes en montrant à retirer et dit
on a appris à danser comme ça mais moi
j'aime pas danser mais il pourrait dire
l'échec du projet il ans symbolise toute
sa réussite
le public rit aux éclats et deux bouts
applaudi luca luca au début pleurait
quand ils devaient danser devant ses
camarades il était mal à l'aise avec son
corps aujourd'hui il peut dire qu'il ne
veut pas danser il peut le dire oh il a
trouvé sa place dans le projet le public
l'a vu a été touché il a su dire
l'expression et l'émotion d'être soi
d'être quelqu'un l'évolution de chacun
des enfants montre combien la danse
place le corps en tant que sujet par un
savoir ancré dans une réalité concrète
et physique il est moyen d'expression et
de réalisation de soi
si l'éducation est fait pour que chacun
trouve sa place dans le monde
j'espère que ce taux qui vous aura
démontré que le corps dans cette
démarche n'est pas le moindre de nos
alliés